au neuvième jour de feu peut être enfin
les premières bonnes nouvelles
l'incendié n'est pas fixé mais il est
moins menaçants l'inquiétude est
générale en france est elle en train le
pet l emploi est en train de vivre une
année historique c'est sans doute le
cinquième ou sixième plus grande ce que
nous ayons eu à connaître par la
superficie qui a été touché les deux
sites le massif des landes de gascogne
c'est le plus grand massif de résineux
d'europe ils représentent un million
d'hectares et nous n'avons pas de
canadair sur site pendant toute la
période estivale notamment caniculaire
ça n'est pas normal qu'à la demande du
président la république dès aujourd'hui
deux hélicoptères deux sociétés privées
seront réquisitionnés et viendront
renforcer notre arsenal malgré tout il
faut être lucide
le changement que nous sommes en train
de vivre et ne touchent pas simplement
la france tout le pourtour méditerranéen
et même au delà du pourtour
méditerranéen totalement inédit au
royaume-uni regarder ces flammes qui
ravagent les habitations d'un quartier
résidentiel
l'objectif est scié et que la sonde ils
n'atteignent pas ce département et comme
vous le voyez juste ici le sable a été
mise à nu sur 300 mètres de large et 5
km de long mais derrière il va falloir
replanter et rebâtir et donc nous allons
très vite lancé les travaux à vos côtés
le faire pour eux lancé un grand
chantier national pour pouvoir replanter
cette formule i mais ils n'y ont pas
leur place y met à niveau cette mascotte
d'une ferme de floride est devenu en
quelques jours la nouvelle coqueluche
des réseaux sociaux
emmanuel est un émeu très curieux
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit de perturber
les vidéos de taylor sa propriétaire il
faut vraiment réfléchir sur la question
du dépérissement et modifier le les
plantations qu'on a dans nos forêts et
puis deux des moyens de lutte qu'ils
fassent qu'on n'ait plus de diversité
sans doute qu'on ait plus de ce qu'on
appelle des pare feu c'est-à-dire des
bandes qui sont sans plantations mais
qui permettent de ralentir en cas d'
incendies et malgré les nombreux
avertissements un moment d'inattention
et emmanuel réussit finalement son coût
n'y a personne sur le plateau de leurs
dépôts ils sont tous en retard tout ce
retard je pense que c'est un coup de la
mairie de paris on va essayer d'enquêté
[Musique]
j'ai commencé quand même les missions
sans un invité pour l'heure des pros oui
mais ce que ce que madame hidalgo un
message pour vous elle m'a dit que ce
qu'elle a fait pour paris elle peut
également le faire pour l'heure des pros
le geste du député de la majorité rémy
rebeyrotte ne passe pas inaperçu
monsieur rebeyrotte ne recommencez plus
que vous avez fait t'as l'air 1 c'était
pas beau ça monsieur reverra atteint
c'est un député qui est coutumier du
fait
un député dans tous les collègues
qu'il passe son temps à
un grand gaillard élu fn que madame le
pen a mis tout au fond sous la tribune
fait un salut nazi je lui signifie de
loin que j'ai vu et qu'il ne faudrait
faire cela c'est aussi un député
surnommé niveau opinion
yaël brunt iv la présidente de
l'assemblée nationale a immédiatement
convoqué monsieur rivero tu quand elle a
eu l'information et quant à nous le
groupe renaissance autour d'aurore
berger bien nous allons avoir un bureau
pour décider des sanctions et le
recevoir également il y en a d'autres
qui insultent entre les coups de casque
et ceux qui bouffent les oreilles des
taxis on a eu quand même droit à toute
une panoplie de députés que dont les
comportements ont été pour le moins
scandaleux la france est devenue un
coupe gorge combien de drames
faudra-t-il pour agir combien de
français battu à mort combien de jeunes
poignardé combien de femmes violées
combien de policiers agressés pour que
votre gouvernement se réveille à nouveau
préfet de police à paris laurent nunez
actuellement fin jusque-là coordonnateur
national du renseignement et de la lutte
contre le terrorisme succède à didier
lallement si par malheur demain vous
étiez au pouvoir on vivre est au pays
des bisounours plus un crime plus une
infraction vous sauriez tout faire mais
je vais vous dire monsieur odoul nous
n'avons ni gérald darmanin nîmois de
leçon à recevoir de vous